for thousands of years I've lain dormant
wait what was they do again oh yeah a
quest that takes me to the Internet's
deepest darkest crevices to find the
bootleg east of the bootlegs you guys
know what I mean those weird fan
animations or live-action movies made
without the consent of the property
holders
you know those unofficial releases that
push the league aligned we aren't
supposed to cross and nowhere is this
legal boundary more blurry than online
so where better to begin than where we
are right now let's check out the fan
animations on YouTube oh my god look at
these view counts I've wasted so many
years doing the wrong damn videos now I
am by no means a legal expert but this
looks a little fishy so maybe it's a
good place to start
hmm master media huh
bad girls are pretty professional and
geez a look it's produced and animated
by the do - I mean huh there's something
about this I just can't quite put my
finger on huh maybe if I look at other
videos
holy crap 23 million views that is
almost 10 million views more than any
episode of Dragon Ball Z abridged I
gotta see this huh it's definitely
something but this is something
bothering me something about it just
seems I don't know off oh wait that's it
of course I can't watch my anime with
these fansubs I gotta get me some of
those authentic Japanese translations
but never stress I happen to have a few
friends living in the Land of the Rising
Sun right now as we speak and you know
what that means
totally nut mark is making an English
dub run meet Nate now alright so this
took a little longer than I thought it
was going to take you see a lot of
Masdar medias videos are reviewable in
Japan so that's certainly not suspicious
now I know what you're all thinking you
can't use his videos in your video
that's infringing his copyrights these
parodies were created either from
scratch as an animation kind of like I
do now do I think that TFS is in the
wrong no I think what they're doing is
parodies and if anybody did that with my
animations they took it they clean the
audio out they chopped it up and they
dubbed over it I would be okay with it I
would be okay with it I will be okay oh
well in that case please everyone sit
back and enjoy some authentic Japanese
translations I present to you all Adam a
war the English dub
[Music]
I you disgusting uncultured [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] about those guys
what beerus the god of destruction
I told you Kakarot that's really
embarrassing Vegeta you don't try your
best it's going to be bad don't help
[ __ ] I'm well able to do this on my
own yeah this guy's bluffing I'm the one
who puts it into this starting from now
you need to be a super sand in your
sleep make it your default state going
forward what what did you say
Super Saiyan damn it there's no way
you're going to defeat me I can tell
without even fighting you do you know
the existence of the Super Saiyan God I
kind of have some business with the
Saiyans over there what kind of problem
you bastard you little [ __ ] there's no
use for this planet anymore ah wow
you're really going for it aren't you
Vegeta I too cannot lose
I don't give a [ __ ] about those guys I
don't want your help
go train and come back when you're
stronger you're young he will soon
surpass me
[Music]
you said I'd fight someone really strong
but you've not used your full power yet
these [ __ ] should be honored it all
depends on your choice it's my hope -
this is good
seriously for real I stand before you
the greatest adventurer in the city the
only adventurer capable of retrieving
the grandchild
Dimitra Phoebus we'll see if you
adventurers are suitable subjects for
the jury Oh Oh neato experiment ok let's
go what what huh I focus my energy I
don't know what's going on destiny has
failed just like it did before
now could cutis I am busy I'll call you
later
whoa what is that key I don't even have
enough power to pick my nose go on this
is the sense of being needed
[Music]
what are you guys looking at tell me you
less than 20 [ __ ] words it's called
the Senzu bean oh hey thanks for coming
piccolo Goku you're talking real
straight huh good job go on
[Music]
I'm gonna pay you back for what you did
to my brother tell me straight no
kidding
if you enter the room as spirit in time
- is that so in that case show me I will
make you a Super Saiyan concentrate
Gohan it's best to start by calming your
Restless mind first in Super Saiyan form
after that let's do some basic training
[Music]
final verdict uh-huh I'm not a [ __ ]
lawyer all right time to move on to some
bootleg movies now I know what you're
thinking mark you'll never find anything
worse or more offensive to my eyes than
Dragonball Evolution and oh yeah I hear
you loud and clear
I can feel those fingers pounding on
those keys right now but have you
considered that in 2009 IGN gave
Dragonball Evolution a positive review
stating that it and I quote is perhaps
the most successful live-action film
today to utilize costume production and
audio design
not to mention some inspired fight
choreography to provide the flavour of
anime without being overly cartoonish
[Music]
yeah alright [ __ ] I did Dragonball
Evolution is widely considered the worst
movie adaptation of an anime property
one of the worst films ever created and
a fantastic example of an out-of-touch
Hollywood cash grab it's currently
sitting with a fifty percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes and with its
10 year anniversary right around the
corner I thought it would be interesting
to see if we could find something that's
maybe worse
but I hear you clamoring what other
live-action Dragon Ball movies have been
created outside of Japan and I hear you
loud and clear borderline offensive
impression of a viewer could there be
perhaps a Dragon Ball movie dare I say
that's worse than Dragonball Evolution
well I've searched the internet far and
wide and believe it or not I have found
two other live-action Dragon Ball movies
that might be up to the challenge just
fair warning people have said that it
gets pretty weird from here on out so
proceed with caution but you guys came
here for the weird stuff right I'm going
to assume you sat there in quiet
agreement anything else would just be
kind of weird well I'm not in the habit
of disappointing people unless you ask
my mom and dad but what do they know so
ready your butt's because this one
should be a weird movie so right off the
bat this movie was created in 1991 and
no it wasn't created in Japan either
it's a Chinese film called Dragon Ball
the magic begins now I don't know about
you but I'm excited for this magic to
begin
granddad this magic pole I can protect
you and the Pearl for many invaders
all right so yeah yeah it's that's a
little out there but that's no big deal
I mean at least all of our favorite
characters are there right we got monkey
boy Seto West would pick piggy miss Snow
White that's a [ __ ] cockatoo [ __ ]
[ __ ] cat that's a [ __ ] white
cockatoo oh and uh of course who could
forget the turtleman
[Music]
and sparkle Sparkle
his name is [ __ ] Sparkle alright I
could get on board with this whole
monkey boy thing and this one's a pretty
cool name but why does grandpa Cohen
sound as though he's named after an
obscure disk cleaner mascot from the
1990s [ __ ] Sparkle okay anyway this
is all pretty much just a live-action
remake of the 1986 Dragon Ball film
curse of the blood rubies or as it was
referred to in Japan The Legend of
Shenlong which was an official
production by Toei animation but you
know what maybe I'm being too harsh in
this movie you know at least the jokes
are good
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and trust me this isn't where the
strange things end either finding a
legitimate copy of this is really tough
it's quite rare and getting your hands
on one will set you back a pretty penny
the only one I could buy it was an
Amazon and it was a hundred and five
dollars I mean I thought it was a good
movie solid purchase totally worth it
quit asking me I mean this was given a
five star review on its website how can
I say no I mean this could have been a
bargain for all I knew and look it even
got a good review
Dragon Ball magic begins it's a great
film to watch if you like anime manga
Dragon Ball Z GT it's very much like
Rocky both monkey boy and monkey have
magic sticks and clouds our friends with
women loving pink demons that own rakes
and is badly dub but for that very funny
well I definitely can't argue with that
now can I jokes aside I could totally
see this movie being a blast to watch
with friends there are some really funny
moments and some genuinely impressive
practical effects and stunt work on
display here it's clear a ton of work
went into making this so if you find
yourself with some spare time and some
spare cash to buy one I recommend
checking it out it had a lot of heart
behind it
all right next up is South Korea's own
dragon ball fight son Goku with son Goku
which let's be honest is probably the
best way of condensing the story of
Dragon Ball into a single title
efficient Korea I like it
let's give it a watch hey you know what
this isn't half bad you've got some cool
shots the kid that's played Goku is
super athletic and the opening music is
really catchy this is going pretty well
did she just unload a machine gun on
Goku in the anime and manga she used a
normal hand gun something someone might
actually have on them why is she
carrying around a machine gun you know
what it's fine this movie has been
really faithful to the original so far -
the submachine gun maybe the first fight
scene will be good
[Music]
some of you dragon ball aficionados out
there might have already noticed that
this movie's retelling the beginning of
the Dragon Balls story around the first
12 episodes or so and it's pretty damn
faithful in a sense so we're 13 minutes
into the movie and we finally get to see
the villains of the feature the peel off
gang hip hop single of the year go get
those dragon balls make you raps
alright it's time for us to wrap it up
to k18 y'all ready sometimes I think I
take jokes too far but that's not even
the best part about this scene no ladies
and gentlemen not by a long shot let me
introduce you to the best part of the
movie I'm not even kidding this guy
steals the show every single one of his
takes is extraordinary but those
highlights don't last because this movie
is filled to the brim with really
awkward scenes like Bulmer giving Goku a
bath made even more weird and creepy
because it's clear that his junk is on
view for the film crew and actors to see
so I'm gonna move swiftly along before I
end up on some government watch list
[Music]
this movie sucks
like wow does it suck everything is
filmed as though they are making the
weirdest creepiest home videos
characters whose appearance is directly
rely on special or practical effects are
laughably bad - [ __ ] terrifying
looks like someone you'd meet at
comic-con who are is literally a stuffed
toy in a string and turtle is made up
entirely of concentrated nightmares and
if you thought the magic begins with a
ripoff this movie is so rare you'd have
trouble finding it in a South Korean
clearance bin a copy of this can go for
as much as two hundred and fifteen
dollars on VHS it doesn't even have an
english dub which means i spent almost
two hours watching this
[Music]
no this movie isn't without its
incredible moments either and by
incredible I mean Yamcha flying spinning
laser car blows a bad guy don't believe
me don't ever say I don't give you
anything man after watching all that
trash I need something to raise my
spirits you know something to get me
back into the dragonballs spirit huh are
there any good bootlegs out there huh
well what's this huh let's check it out
I'm saying it now
I haven't even dis well since lunch
actually it's pronounced launch veg
eater wait wait what what did she just
say hey go back here breaking news from
the coxal corpses oh my god this is pork
hey guys that sure was something wasn't
it totally didn't record this before I
wrote the script by the way can you
believe I said that thing about that guy
and man how about those bootlegs huh
weren't they really bad and/or really
good depending on your current point of
view which I'm totally in agreement with
a real talk though thanks a ton for
watching I'm really sorry this took so
long the YouTube algorithm probably
really hates me right now so it would
really mean a lot to me if you guys
would maybe like the video and if you
feel up to it share it with your friends
if you thought it was good enough until
next time though guys thank you so much
for watching
aaah unintelligible audio we couldn't
figure out the meaning of this one hire
some damn force actors you cheapskate